I'm okay right now I've had moments of
not being okay the new season of The
Real Housewives of New York will show
Bethenny Frankel going through a serious
health scare tell Meghan that she has to
find out if I have a living will
Bethenny clears the air with ETS it is
and has been scary I have a couple of
different female issues going on at the
same time that have created kind of the
perfect storm so I am dealing with it
there were even rumors Frankel is facing
cancer I don't have cancer I don't I
don't want to say I don't have cancer I
don't even like that that word is sort
of out there season 8 premieres
Wednesday Bethenny told us how important
it's been to stay strong for her young
daughter we can live lives our lives
selfish and single and that's one thing
but when you're the health issue and you
have a child it makes you think all
these different things you would never
normally think watch ET Monday night for
more from Bethany including the latest
on her divorce drama